not so many years ago travel between
continents was a major undertaking and
few persons that either the time or the
money required for such long journeys
today air transportation has reduced the
world in size until no area on earth is
more than 60 hours away this change has
brought many new problems preventing the
introduction of foreign diseases into
the United States is one of the most
important of these problems
within seven hours flying time of the
United States there are areas in which
dengue and yellow fever are endemic from
the jungles of Africa and South America
these diseases may be brought to our
shores by air travelers most of our
ports of entry are within areas where
the Aedes aegypti mosquito vector of
both dengue and yellow fever is already
present our first line of defense
against these diseases is the quarantine
officer it is his duty to prevent the
entry into this country of infected
passengers or mosquitoes essential
preventive measures are one the
destruction of insects brought in with
the plane and identification of those
that are found - checking vaccination
certificates of persons originating in
or passing through yellow fever
countries and three careful examination
of passengers our second line of defense
is the control of the Aedes aegypti
mosquito breeding this is the job of the
Egypt eye control inspector
in many South Atlantic and Gulf Coast
cities the Egypt eye control unit is
working to reduce the hazard of
introduction of dengue and yellow fever
in order to successfully apply proper
control measures the inspector must be
familiar with the habits of this sly
biting mosquito the Aedes aegypti
mosquito breathes in and around homes
it rarely flies more than a hundred
yards
Aedes Egypt I eggs are generally found
at the water level on the sides of
containers these are the larvae commonly
known as wiggle tails these are the
pupae with an adult emerging there are
four stages in the life cycle of the
mosquito egg larva pupa and adult about
ten days are required to complete the
cycle from egg to adult
notice the white tipped pouch the
triangular white spots on the abdomen
the white leg bands and the white lyre
shape design on the thorax these are
characteristic of the adult Egypt eye
mosquito this is a group of inspectors
similar to the group of which you are a
member after you understand the habits
of the mosquito and the methods of
control you will become an important
member of the Egypt eye control program
the necessary equipment is simple
notebook report forms larvacide
applicator flashlight pipette chalk
dipper mirror kerosene pointed hammer
and satchel to completely eliminate
Egypt eye breeding an inspection zone
must be covered every 10 days this
period represents the life cycle of
Aedes aegypti from eggs to adults as you
work through your zone use special
markings so that you can be located
easily by your supervisor
before entering a premise to make an
inspection marks the first half of a V
on the sidewalk or fence regardless of
the type home you enter always be
pleasant and courteous once inside your
work begins you will recognize these as
the gypped I larvae the s-shaped
swimming motion is characteristic of
this species encourage the housewife to
grow plants in Paris rather than in
water take larval specimens so that
identification may be confirmed remove
the plant and scrub the edges of the
bowl to destroy the eggs rinse the roots
thoroughly to eliminate larvae
and guards may be a source of Egypt I
breathing in this case they are treated
with kerosene barrels and drums are
frequent sources of Egypt I breeding for
best visibility use a mirror to reflect
sunlight into dark containers avoid
jarring the container before dipping
because Egypt I'll RV will quickly dive
to the bottom this disturb
Lavie are concentrated at the bottom of
the Dipper by pouring off excess water
this facilitates the transfer of larvae
from differ to vile kerosene is applied
in only two cases first where poisonous
larvicides might be dangerous and second
to water in which the non feeding pupae
are found in areas where water is scarce
cisterns are used to store rainwater
cisterns may be prolific breeding places
because they contain water throughout
the year
examine trash buckets rain water or
wastewater is often found in such
containers and if not too dirty Egypt I
will breed there
larvicide all receptacles of this type
or turn them bottoms up old discarded
tires containing water are frequent
breeding places after removing the water
larvacide and store undercover
tell the householder about the
conditions found and how to prevent
mosquito breeding a completed V will
indicate that the inspection is finished
make a fall report after each inspection
when beginning a new block indicates the
direction of travel the date and time of
day and your initials so that you can be
easily located no home is immune to
Aedes Egypt I as long as water
containers are present housewives will
soon learn to recognize you the
invitation to enter is usually cordial
if not either explained the purpose of
your visit more fully or thank the
householder and refer the matter to the
Foreman Walker's standing in flower
containers is a definite hazard even
when no breeding is found request the
housewife to change the water at least
once every five days as a preventive
measure
when breeding is found the stem should
be rinsed to remove larvae and the
containers scrubbed to eliminate
attached eggs phenothiazine may be added
to fresh water to prevent breeding after
the interior has been examined inspect
the yard
in the search for water containers look
under over around and if possible
through any object you encounter
when no one is at home proceed to
examine the yard call back later to
inspect the house
breeding containers such as paint
buckets unused washed tubs and tin cans
are frequently found around the yard
work in a routine and careful manner to
avoid overlooking any breeding places
even though no larvae or pupae are found
in a container the water should be
emptied in the container inverted when
not in use septic tanks often hold
accumulations of clear water in which
Egypt I will breathe
complete the V but pops it to indicate
that the interior has not been examined
every promise in the zone must be
examined a thorough search is made in
all vacant buildings
sometimes containers are placed under
leaky roofs to catch rainwater such
containers must be inspected emptied and
treated with larvacide to prevent
breeding openings to a cistern are often
difficult to locate they may be
concealed under floor coverings
furniture or trash in such places may be
hidden mother full-sized that's
producing gypped I continuously and
infest an entire neighborhood
fill out a request for special
corrective measures unused closet bowls
and flush tanks should be treated with
alarm aside since they are frequent
breeding places
dispose of tin cans or puncture them so
they won't hold water complete the
circuit of the ground
a days inspection will probably include
the reporting of accumulations of tin
cans such as this after the day's
activities report to headquarters
identification of specimens is checked
by the supervisor
the presence of pupae indicates imminent
emergence of adults in such cases adult
spraying is necessary on the following
day at the beginning of each day's work
form enough special crews are assigned
work which inspectors are unable to
handle such as large-scale larva
sighting introduction of fish for
permanent corrective measures a cleanup
crew may be necessary when refuse is not
collected by other municipal agencies
records show that three-fourths of all
Egypt tie breeding occurs in tin cans
bottles and other refuse not only is
breeding prevalent in such containers
but eggs remain there through the winter
special equipment is necessary for
larvae sighting scrap piles an abandoned
cistern such as this may need a light
film of oil or stocking with fish the
fish crew is probably the most important
single service unit several species of
the genus Gambia commonly called top
minnows or mosquito fish will eat the
larvae usually these minnows are
collected from local ponds cisterns have
been known to remain stuffed with Gambia
for several years a watertight marine
laughs is useful when treating dark
secluded places
when the only opening into a cistern is
the lead-in pipe from the roof gutter or
the air vent fish can be poured into a
rubber hose and flushed into the cistern
with additional water cisterns and you
should have all opening screens this is
a well sealed system a new system should
be destroyed or filled
a special crew inspects all roof gutters
one of the main jobs is to keep the
gutters clear of leaves and branches
thus preventing accumulations of water
in which Egypt I may breathe when water
is found it is swept out a maritime crew
may be needed in seaports to inspect
boats a light film of kerosene will
control breathing in water Cakes cabins
are sprayed to kill adults flower
containers in cemeteries are ideal
mosquito breeding places a special
assignment may be necessary for
effective control
the continued presence of adult
mosquitoes after all routine control
measures have been employed indicate
some undetected breeding place or mother
focus no possibility should be
overlooked in searching for such a
hazards
perseverance and tedious effort are
often necessary in searching for these
continuously producing Poe sighs
although such a focus is usually a heavy
breeder it may not be large in size
when discovered inspection will reveal
all stages of the mosquito the adult
should be sprayed immediately to prevent
any further infestation adults in the
vicinity of the focus must also be
sprayed the mother focus is reported so
that permanent correction may be made
you as an Egypt eye inspector have been
assigned important work which must be
done thoroughly the success of the
program depends upon your conscientious
effort and your ability to integrate
Aedes Egypt I work with other official
sanitation activities just as the Egypt
eye control program depends on you so
must you depend upon gaining the
goodwill of the residents within your
zone impress upon your people the urgent
necessity for mosquito control to
protect themselves and their neighbors
show them in a pleasant and courteous
manner the methods of eliminating the
adjectival encourage each householder to
be his own inspector thus you will play
a vital role in the public health
programme of your community
[Music]